sechs wochen vor dem start
jetzt ist die kunde aus spielerischen
vorstellung läuft mittlerweile noch
derzeit an musik lebt ja der herr stück
fertig sondern zivile merkels besuch es
muss ja erst einmal schwer abschätzen wo
man ein schaden entstehen freie größter
popstar aber mit der zeit hat diesen
sommer wechseln rationiert wird putzen
ja jeweiligen unterkunft in einem
rucksack zusammen richten
die angelobung vorbereiten so schnell
ist jetzt die grundausbildung schon
wieder vorbei wir hoffen ein paar
eindrücke mitnehmen kinder und es soll
ein
und da das heißt das letzte video bei
der angelobung ich genauso gefreut wie
die ordnung projekt
vor allem sehr geehrten damen und herren
begrüßte die erhöhung 318 gerichtskosten
von über eine million mal sagen sie sie
die etwas kommando führung main hannover
soll sich der hingelegt werden möge der
tasche liegen angehören
die schilderungen bleiben
meine damen und herren ist nicht sicher
dass sich hier in diesem
außergewöhnlichen ort eher locker gruppe
vom nationalpark hohe tauern
die angelobung der jungen roten
durchführen dürfen
in diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen allen
eine gute zeit beim österreichischen
bundesheer eine zeit auch die kleine
zurückblicken
[Musik]
zum höher
[Applaus]
möglich wurde die sorge
[Musik]
ich hab da mal so